rescue workers in morocco have been
working tirelessly for days to save a
five-year-old boy who fell into a well
crowds have flocked to the village of
igran to cheer on the rescuers officials
say they're getting close to the boy but
that conditions are dangerous and the
rescue is in a challenging phase
throngs of people watch as rescuers race
to save a boy's life
little ryan has been stuck 32 meters
down this well since tuesday
he was playing until the middle of the
day
he was with me at first
but then i looked for him and couldn't
find him
after searching we realized that he fell
into the well
now we are praying to god
at less than half a meter wide the well
is too narrow to pull the boy out
rescuers use ropes to lower oxygen and
water as well as a closed circuit camera
to check on his health
on thursday a rescuer was able to go
down a parallel hole that had been dug
to get closer to rayon
i managed to communicate with the child
and asked if he could hear me
there was a response
i waited for a minute and saw that he
began using the oxygen
once rescuers were able to dig down to
the depth where ryan is stuck
they began excavating a horizontal
tunnel to try and reach the boy
but the loose soil has slowed their
efforts
gripped by the boy's terrifying plight
many have come to cheer on the rescuers
or even to volunteer
but authorities have asked them to stand
back and let them do the work
many people from the region came to the
site of the accident and some even spent
the night there little ryan touched them
and everyone is praying for him
officials said on friday that they were
just meters away from reaching ryan
a police helicopter is waiting to take
him to the hospital as soon as he is
freed